[Music]
when I was growing up there were nine
planets in the solar system until one
day that number dropped to eight
Pluto had been demoted from Planet Hood
and I took that personally
I think a lot of other people did too
that is why I've come all the way out
here to the edge of the solar system to
proved once and for all that Pluto is a
planet
yeah
Nico what's up Ram do you think Pluto is
a planet
no no
this video is not going to a good start
here is Pluto a planet I believe so yep
that's what they taught me in science
class yes or no is Pluto a planet I want
to say no probably probably but I guess
all these scientists are telling us it's
not anymore it looks like a planet it's
got atmosphere it even has a heart
unlike you need a little noise talking
about of course it's a planet Pluto is
100 a planet I don't care what any
science guys say if Pluto's not a planet
then what is a planet I just learned all
the planets and I was really proud of
myself I remember talking to my mom and
telling her all the planets I knew and
then I went to school the next day
suddenly Pluto's not a planet Pluto's a
planet and I think I'm right
is Pluto a planet
no
Pluto may not have been discovered until
1930 but astronomers already knew it had
to be there thanks to math good old math
you see Neptune's orbits was behaving a
little uh unexpectedly so it was
theorized that an object dubbed Planet X
had to be tugging on it Elizabeth
Williams an astronomer mostly forgotten
by history unfortunately calculated
where it must be and so then 15 years
later Clyde Tombaugh finally found it
people were so hyped that Walt Disney
even changed the name of Mickey Mouse's
dog amazingly there was no way for them
to know that we'd someday discover a
striking resemblance between them
these incredible high-res photos were
taken in 2015 by the New Horizons space
probe a team of Pluto fans spent five
years preparing the mission and then
another nine years waiting for it to
arrive with just months after New
Horizons launched into space Pluto fans
were greeted with a nasty surprise
Pluto had been unceremoniously stripped
of its Planet Hood
how dare they I mean my very educated
mother just served us nine pizzas what's
she supposed to serve us now ninjas in
2006 the iau redefined what makes a
planet a planet by using three criteria
it needs to orbit a star and needs to be
spherical in shape and it needs to have
cleared its Cosmic neighborhood and
we'll go through all three of these
throughout the rest of this video oh
well then this should be easy I mean
Pluto goes around the Sun check although
sure it's over it might be a little
drunk yeah no it's a party it's also so
off-center that sometimes Pluto is
closer to the Sun than Neptune but hey
still counts what's interesting about
this first criteria is that has nothing
to do with size I mean Callisto IO and
Europa are all bigger than Pluto but
they don't orbit the sun they orbit
Jupiter making the moons not planets
yeah moons are the sort of things you
could find around planets Pluto's got
five of them just saying by having moons
is not a criteria for Planet Hood most
of Pluto's moons are pretty small too
except for Sharon Karen Sharon karon
charnon charandar I'm so sorry I'm
getting I'll get back to the video
Sharon which is actually the largest
moon in the solar system relative to the
body it orbits Sharon is almost half the
size of Pluto in fact they're close
enough in size that Pluto kind of orbits
Sharon back think of it like the Olympic
hammer throw even though these dudes are
massive the ball they're swinging around
is heavy enough that they both actually
spin around a point between them and the
same thing happens between Pluto and
Sharon as you can see with the scale
model right here Pluto actually orbits a
point outside of its own body called the
Berry Center where I'm standing the
location of this point is determined by
the ratio of mass between the two
orbiting bodies and in the case of Pluto
that's about 1300 kilometers off of its
surface but if the mass of these two
bodies were the same then the Berry
Center would sit in a point perfectly in
the middle between them wait okay so if
Pluto and Sharon are orbiting each other
then is Pluto not orbiting the Sun oh
wait yeah no this happens with Earth and
our moon too you see the Earth doesn't
just rotate in place like this it
actually orbits around a berry Center
about a thousand miles under your feet
right now that's about three quarters
from the center of the earth most people
don't realize it but Earth wobbles too
it's just that in the case of Pluto that
wobble is so extreme that is sometimes
considered to be a binary system
orbiting the Sun orbiting the Sun
so it still counts
still counts
speaking of the sun though am I the only
one who thought it would be darker here
I always envisioned Pluto as being too
far from the Sun to get enough light to
see in reality though it's about as
bright as those first few minutes after
Sunset called Civil Twilight that's
enough to read a book or even burn your
eyes if you look right at it kind of
looks like a welding Arc
although at this this isn't something
the sun does not provide much of is heat
cause boy is it cold naturally
Antarctica holds the record for the
coldest temperature ever recorded on
earth at negative 90 degrees Celsius but
that's nothing compared to how cold
liquid nitrogen is which is even a
hundred degrees colder but a negative
230 degrees Celsius Pluto is cold enough
that nitrogen freezes solid look at this
I'm standing on nitrogen ice
in fact 98 of Pluto's surface's Frozen
nitrogen including the giant
heart-shaped Basin called
sputnikplanation it's believed that a
massive impact event billions of years
ago left it as a permanent scar which is
still geologically active today these
are called convection cells where warm
ice gets pushed up from below as the
cold eye slips back down every 500 000
years making this a lot like a cosmic
lava lamp that's cradled by massive
mountains except on Pluto Rock isn't
actually Rock it's water these mountains
might be as big as the Rockies back home
but they're made entirely out of IC H2O
it is so cold here that nitrogen acts
like water ice and the water acts like
Granite what's even more amazing is that
scientists believe there is a giant
ocean of liquid H2O water entirely below
the crust of Pluto yeah the magma inside
of Pluto is just liquid water just like
how the magma inside of Earth is liquid
rock there are even freaking volcanoes
here
cryovolcanoes Pluto's surprisingly the
Earth-like except everything's like an
octave colder if that makes sense cool
so what's the deal with all the red
stuff oh this is really cool they're
called tholens Pluto has a surprisingly
large atmosphere mostly nitrogen that is
sublimated off the ground but there's
some methane in it too and methane
undergoes a transformation when
bombarded by cosmic rays from the Sun it
breaks it down and then recombines it
into complex hydrocarbons which then
fall to the ground like red snow that's
why Pluto has such striking red
Landscapes and we can see similar areas
on other worlds like Europa it's even
hypothesized that tholens are what make
Jupiter's big red spot well red then
what exactly is this stuff is it special
stick with me for a moment because I'm
getting to something incredible yes
Thorns are special because they're
composed of things like amino acids and
nucleotides which are the building
blocks for protein and DNA the lens are
literally the ingredients for life
itself
but that is not the incredible part
check out where the tholan deposits are
deepest and these names there's the
Cthulhu region the morgoth region in the
balrog region seriously shout out to the
naming committee these names are awesome
there's even a stolen deposit on Sharon
called Mordor
Mordor
that means there's an actual real place
in the solar system containing the
ingredients for life and its name is
Mordor Mordor
incredible
although I wonder if that has anything
to do with it being a place there's
absolutely nothing to do with being a
planet sorry I just got distracted by
how cool Pluto is anyway where was I the
second criteria for Planet Hood is that
a planet's mass must be large enough
that its own gravitational forces
overcome the strength of the materials
making it up forcing it into Nature's
most efficient shape a sphere oh come on
did you think I wasn't going to have a
tennis ball in this video
I'm so sorry now Pluto is obviously big
enough to be spherical but how big is
big enough at almost 2 400 kilometers in
diameter Pluto is half the width of the
United States and Sputnik Polynesia how
big is that it's the size of Texas Mr
President thanks Mr Graham Norton it
would take longer to fly from Seattle to
Tokyo than it would to fly all the way
around Pluto
wait did I say Graham Norton
Billy Bob Thornton I said Edward Norton
Graham Norton God dang it that is
significantly smaller than our own moon
but is still significantly bigger than
Sharon which is also still round I mean
what is the threshold for roundness your
mom
the minimum size required to become
spherical depends on a few things like
density of the material for objects
mostly made of rock that's about 600
kilometers in diameter Pluto which is
mostly ice is less dense than Earth
meaning it would still be spherical at
just 400 kilometers across also Pluto is
more spherical than Earth so not only
does Pluto meet the second criteria it
passes with a perfect score all right
that's what I'm talking about yeah oh
yeah I almost forgot the gravity on
Pluto is just six percent that of Earth
meaning that I can jump 17 times higher
here than back home can you imagine
playing basketball like this I mean
Michael Jackson's 46 inch vertical would
be 63 feet here not even his arm can get
that long all right bring it on what's
the third criteria
foreign
about that it must be big enough that
its own gravity cleared away any other
objects of similar size near its orbit
around the sun
huh okay this one requires a little bit
of unpacking so to understand it let's
look at series it's round it orbits the
Sun but it does so in the asteroid belt
so it's got a lot of neighbors even
though it's almost a thousand kilometers
in diameter it doesn't have enough
gravity to deflect capture or merge with
all the other objects in the asteroid
belt so Ceres can't be a planet which
brings us back to Pluto because the
problem is that Pluto lives in the
Kuiper belt surprise we have another
asteroid built in the solar system but
this donut-shaped belt is out beyond the
orbit of Neptune and is home to hundreds
of thousands of objects many of many of
which are similar in size to Pluto in
fact it was the discovery of Eris in
2005 that became the Catalyst for all of
this reclassification not only is Eris
almost exactly the same size as Pluto
it's
although to be to be fair
or drunk than Pluto's still counts if
Pluto is a planet then heiress would be
two so it's Ceres so would orcas salacia
kwar makimaki gong gong this goes on
these were all planets how would we even
remember them many very educated
children may Just Surrender upon
numbering planets on school quizzes
moronically given every semester
we can't make Pluto a planet without
including 87 other objects some of which
don't even have names yet
I failed
I'm sorry Pluto fans
Pluto can't be a planet Pluto can't be a
planet unless
I make it one wait what so all Pluto
needs to do to become a planet it's just
clear its neighborhood right yeah what
are you doing
clear in the neighborhood
yes yes yes
I did it I turned the whole Kuiper belts
into Super Pluto it is now officially a
planet
the Fallen fields are buried
the nitrogen Glaciers are shattered and
the cryo volcanoes that are gone
what have I done
listen it's okay to feel an emotional
connection to Pluto if you grew up with
it as part of your Celestial family
having to accept that change is well
it's sad but we focused on it for so
long now that the most famous thing
about Pluto isn't any of the amazing
geology the most famous thing about
Pluto is that it's not a planet anymore
and that kind of makes me more sad
because Pluto is such an amazing world
full of incredible features all of which
have absolutely nothing to do with its
status as a planet
[Music]
foreign
then what is it well it's a dwarf planet
dwarf planet planet planet is still in
the name yeah planet has always been in
the name so it still counts
yep yeah sure still counts it still
counts
if you can find room in your heart to
accept this wonderful little dwarf
planet for what it is instead of what
you want it to be I have a feeling Pluto
will accept you too
thanks for watching
[Applause]